[Music]
don't be a fake don't be a flake
don't run away from your feelings babe
don't be afraid
don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey babe
hey babe hey babe hey
hey babe i love you so
and i want you to know that
i'm gonna miss your love
the minute you walk out that door
please don't go hey baby babe how are
you doing i'm doing good so steve cohen
yes the mess
okay i do i get a gig yes you told me
about this
like when you happen like a week ago and
i told you
don't tell me a word you got to tell me
on the podcast for the first time i
i bombed like
i'm talking about one of the owner of
the met the owner of the mets hired you
to do a private show
the owner of the mets and also tommy
mottola the big music industry exactly
mariah carey's ex
husband okay it's there is there tommy
mottola
that's a song okay
so so so first of all by the way i
started off by name i said tommy mottola
i thought that it was motorola i was
like i used to have your cell phone as a
kid he said it's motorola
and i said okay so
so you you tried to do a a bespoke joke
so yeah so i'm fast forwarding a little
bit let me get
started set the scene completely it's at
this restaurant in the city
which was a beautiful restaurant he's
the owner of the mets he owns
the new york metropolitan politics
billionaire
the show billions was created after his
life or
from our good friend dan soder you know
i i haven't seen billions everyone else
[Music]
is
great special based off steve cohen's
life so okay
so big money great guy steve cohen let
me tell you something getting to meet
this guy great i love that this guy is
great guys
based off his life based off his life so
how i got the gig was
his wife is puerto rican i do jokes
okay i do jokes about you know puerto
rican women in my life because i have
puerto rican children
girlfriend you're puerto rican friends
puerto rican you're puerto rican
well but it's really it's what's cuban
though aren't you cuban
more puerto more puerto rico yeah my
grandma is 100 puerto rican
yes and my grandpa is is is partial he's
cuban and uh spanish
yes dude and puerto rican i'm puerto
rican everywhere yeah you're
you're probably though i'm pr i'm poor
i'm i'm puerto rican
puerto rico so puerto ricans so what
happens was
is the gig i get the gig
from i get they reach out to me to do
the gig because
i i my friend emilio who owns uh new
york comic con we know and love emilio
shout out new york comedy club forever
in the new york city area go to new york
comedy club two locations two locations
emilio gets in touch somehow they get in
touch somehow with amelo because he
books all these corporate gigs and he's
great and his brother works for morgan
stanley and all these things
but they get in touch with him steve
cohen's wife
puerto rican his children has puerto
rican children first of all second has
about eight kids it's like he's amish
but a couple of those children are
puerto rican
from his current wife so she uh
allegedly liked my stand-up because i do
all the stuff about puerto rico stephen
corn has no idea who i am okay the
birthday party we run to the impression
was gonna be a family birthday party
okay so they a family birthday party so
i'm going to go up do comedy for the
family the wife knows
hon this is my i like this comic book
you were bringing out puerto rican
content
i was literally like all i'm going to do
is my puerto rican jokes because that's
what
you got to make the wife happy wife
happy life she'll laugh at him whatever
steve will say all right this kid's in
yeah okay
it's ten guys upstairs added private
tate they rented out the entire
restaurant the terrace the balcony of
the restaurant is in on park avenue new
york city traffic honking away 6 p.m
i could hear the cars from downstairs to
win wrestling new york city day
10 guys 10 billionaires sitting at a
table getting sir food martinis
you know penguin meat all the exotic
stuff they have no idea
a comedy show is gonna happen oh the
worst no one ever tells them a comic's
coming
hey we just added tickets providence
rhode island
philadelphia pennsylvania we have opened
them up go to chrisdcomedy.com those
tickets were sold out forever
but we added seats capacity uh no more
chrissy half capacity now it's chrissy
full capacity
go to christy comedy.com providence july
22nd to the 24th
and uh uh philadelphia pennsylvania
august 18th to the 21st
go to christy comedy.com that tt jerry's
phone is ringing he will be there
but he can't leave state lines but once
he's allowed to he's going to start
coming to my shows
no one ever says the comics coming on
nothing they never they have no idea
it's about to happen it's a surprise for
steve okay okay i get up there
the shirt first of all were you wearing
would you wear a met jersey no i wore
like a button-down
like like a button-down shirt yeah
i should have yeah i wore a daryl
strawberry
so i get there i get there i go to you
know start the show there's
no microphone no nothing the guy one of
the friends who's just like a fun guy
like everybody was fun one of the guys
he doesn't know who i am he goes are you
the comic i go yeah he goes what's your
name
i go chris the stephanie goes i'll never
remember that so i go great
so he's going to introduce me so amelia
me and emil are like this is going to go
back amelia's with you yes he's giving
me martinis which i told you i never had
a martini
oh you're drinking martinis before the
show before the show because i never got
into martinis and i said to emilia i
said i've never drank a martini first
said trust me you're gonna love it this
is the drink of an adult
yeah so i started drinking the martinis
i'm like you're right i i now now i
can't stop
straight out i put on four pounds i
don't even because i'm not factoring the
martinis into my infinity war i don't
see the four i'll see him
so i'm doing and then and then somebody
asked me what kind of martini was it i
said i have no idea what's dry wet
neat dirty i don't know that's all
different things but sure yeah i just
got it it was great
so so the guy the guy um i think his
name was ted
he goes yeah i'll never remember your
name i say yeah he goes yeah we don't
have a microphone
i go don't tell me i go i go okay i go
well where's the show he goes at
the front i figure you just stand in
front of the table there's no stage
no light no nothing it's six o'clock
it's outside on a roof deck
so you could hear the new york city
traffic the waiter's waitresses don't
even know there's a comedy show
they're serving dinner and serving
drinks i'm standing now
i didn't get you a mic they come
the waiter says they tell the staff hey
can we get this guy mike
the owner comes up with the mic he goes
hey we have a mic but no pa system
so i said so what do you mean so just
just for just for your motion yeah it
was just for physicality so it was like
he was like it's a mic but you know we
don't have we don't have time to
you know echo it through the pa system
so we can just give you a dead mic
i said okay i'll take it you
you took it you did stand up with a dead
mic
just for the for the cause just for that
just because i was like a muscle memory
i gotta have something yeah what are you
doing letterman yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
you're gonna do it out of my mind
one of my madonna i just got the
earpiece yeah janet jackson rhythm
nation yeah what the hell is going on
yeah so now i have a dead mic
for these that yeah so it's not
amplified whatsoever
not what's up yeah okay whatever so i
was getting you know good money it's a
corporate gig whatever good money you
know steve's a billionaire very generous
guy great guy
i get up there i literally go hey guys
i go i'm the you know uh ted brings me
up i forgot i forgot to say
because he said i'll never remember that
ted goes he goes hey he goes steve you
gotta surprise me he got a comic
he goes you guys probably don't know who
he is he goes i forgot his name but i
heard he's funny
he goes all right kid come on so uh i
swear to god i'm walking out with the
dead mike
i say i say ted what an introduction i
really appreciate it
i said you really know how to make a
girl feel welcome thinking oz get a
little laugh
that didn't get a laugh steve cohen
turns to me
and goes literally i'm talking about sal
i'm on stage for eight seconds
he goes how long did they tell you to do
i said 45 minutes he goes
no chance you're making 45 minutes he
goes i'll double whatever they're paying
you right now to do 10 minutes
did he mean it because that's an amazing
deal you take that i said to him i said
i said what is this christmas i said
you're going to give me twice the money
to do 10 minutes he said
absolutely he goes we want to get back
to the dinner i swear to god it was
happy but also i'm like wow i'm gonna
bomb
in that moment i felt a bead of sweat
traveling down my spine
vertebrae by vertebrae until it it
puddled onto the top of my ass crack
yeah just i mean a full cold
sweat just bang yes so then i start
doing show first joke come out of the
gate
come out of the gate i say because it's
a bobby bonilla joke bobby bonilla
has been being paid by you have a bobby
bonilla joke i don't have a body of me
i know he's i know he's he's wasting
their whole entire budget right they're
uh
yes yeah yeah yeah yeah so you're
wasting time because they're still
paying this i'm still getting paid he
hasn't been on the match for 25 years
i'm like i'm like oh steve i just want
to make sure i get
the money i said i don't want a bobby
bonilla deal i want it all up front i
had to kill
nothing zero they're like no they're
like just looking at me okay so then i
say ted
i say i say um i say then i say
who who do we got here i said who we got
here you know whatever and then steve
goes oh this is uh this is tommy mottola
and i said oh
i loved your cell phones as a kid he
goes that's motorola
right so then then ready then i try
another joke i forgot what i say
bombs the only laugh i get of the night
exploded with laughter
this is about seven minutes into the set
oh by the way
i i'm literally in the middle of a bit
i'm in the middle of a bit one of the
bits
because i was just doing old school once
like you know the joke i heard i'm like
oh three years one [ __ ] when i'm like
i'm dating this girl it's what i used to
close on
christopher christopher it's like it's
like a bit that i haven't done because
i'm like you know trying to work on the
new stuff but i'm like i have no choice
you're doing blow job material at steve
cohen's birthday because it's ten guys
because in my opinion it's for ten guys
for ten billionaires in their fifties
and sixties they either wanna
they either wanna have jerry seinfeld
come out right or hookers
right one of the other right
six-year-old guy that nobody knows
doing comedy the only person knew i was
there was steve cohen's son who's also
half puerto rican
he came up to me after he said he goes
that was brutal he goes but i'm a big
fan
and then he said to me he said to me
i'll dm you tomorrow i'll dm you
tomorrow
you come sit and sweet with me and my
dad in the mets game he'll love you if
the guys aren't here i that was
that gig was ten days ago no d no no no
no no i've been checking
like like a supermodel told me she was
going to be refreshed zero zero zero
from steve cohen's son but great kid
shout out steve cohen's son
great steve cohen's son if you're if
you're watching and we know you are yeah
hit him with the dm
get him up in the nation shout out
sweets so it became a thing where steve
cohen
started asking me questions it became a
podcast with me and steve cohen steve
was like where you from
told him where i'm from trying to do
he's doing crowd work on youtube was
literally doing crown racking nobody's
laughing
one one guy one guy one guy said he goes
he goes oh
he goes um he goes uh he goes oh yeah
our friend bill down there
he lost 50 pounds uh from from his
recent divorce
he goes you think but what do you think
he realized to 50 pounds when i was like
i don't know cancer and he was like
yeah how'd you know and i was like oh my
god
i swear to god and i was like i was like
oh
i'm i'm so sorry i'm like legitimately
like you know so sorry
i apologize and then and then and then
steve goes i'm just with you
place explodes oh my god oh god no
so he gets the biggest laugh no the
biggest laugh of the night is what i got
off on which was crowd work with montola
i didn't say anything but steve said
that's enough
i go to tommy mottola i saw your mariah
carey's
ex-ex-husband i said you know what i
used to love mariah carey as a kid he
goes i guess you also love [ __ ] as a kid
explodes explode steve carter almost
falls out of the seat
i say thank you good night i appreciate
it you've all been great
they start clapping it up they gives me
twice as much of the money i sent an
email
with the emilio to that to the to the
guy who put it all together
the next morning so we're so sorry that
was an impossible situation you have to
understand chris is excellent at these
gigs or you know he's he this is his
word it's not mine he said
he is our guy for the corporate gigs
because he can stick and move right do
the crowd work but it was impossible the
waiter and wait steph
they were bumping into him nobody was
listening wasn't the right move they
write back no mike
they write they right back we don't know
what you're talking about steve loved
him
are you serious i swear to god they go
steve loved him wow
you'll be hearing from us again we like
to book them on more parties we loved
them i was like
[Laughter]
what the hell tell me someone threw
something at you oh yes
so i get yeah so i literally
tommy mottola tommy mattola and i are
because dude there was so
there were so many [ __ ] things that
happened in that not during that night
that i can't believe
i forgot about that and emilio and
you're like you're martini
you're my teeny tipsy i wish i wish and
pray
that we could it's one of those things
where like it was one of those gigs
where i literally i bet you there's
probably 10 things that i'm forgetting
to tell you that emilio can tell you
because i just
literally the things that were happening
were like unbelievable
amazing so i'm doing the show i'm doing
you know like whatever
maybe because maybe i did 15 minutes
roughly you know what i mean
but i'm literally i don't know maybe six
seven minutes in
crab cakes come out
[Laughter]
come out the crab cakes come out one
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's
so crab cakes come out so i'm doing bits
i'm doing the bits i'm doing now i'm
going into material
when i like used to be physical
therapist like i'm just doing i'm
forgetting like my material
i'm trying to do jokes about covid
everything's working the crab cakes come
out they're eating the crabs
right there so one of the guys a couple
guys down from montola
cotsa is cutting a piece of crab cake
goes like
[Laughter]
i'm in the middle of the bed he's cause
you have to understand another part of
this gig what what you have to say is
i'm not on stage or anything i'm
standing
at the table my leg is touching the back
of somebody's chair
okay so i am literally as if i was
standing at a table
like right across like you're you could
the people across table could touch me
yes you have no
you have no presence nothing you're
you're lost in the crowd
nothing there's no respect there's
nothing amplifying your voice is that
you're just you're just yeah yeah
i forgot what joke i did it was probably
like in the moment crowd work
bit but something happened where i
actually got like a laugh like a
relatively big laugh
as in the middle of the laugh where in
my head i'm saying thank god i finally
got one
in slow motion i see half of a crab cake
with sauce on top of it
land and hit me right in the chest so
now i have a crab cake stain
all over my chest someone threw a crab
cake at you and then he goes and then
you go
in the middle of the laughter so i was
thinking in my head oh maybe like
because of the boisterous laughter
thank god go get with the crab cake the
guy says i'm so sorry and then the guy
two down goes no he's not he meant to do
it
big lamb wow so steve cohen then dips a
napkin
in ice water gives me the napkin and
just let's yo just wipes off my chest
it was one of those things where i was
just like what is happening
okay are you in your head being like
are you feeling the bomb feeling or are
you feeling like
this is so wild i don't care let me tell
you something let me tell you something
when i got in you felt like a stomach
when i got back into my car
i had to take off my butt down because
it was so
haha yeah actually yeah let me read
sweat is a sign of yeah
let me let me read the text because
because not that far back let me just
because there's probably three search
crab cake that'll get it because that's
how i knew
yeah hold on because when you texted me
that i almost swerved off the road okay
okay
here we go here he goes i go i go i go
um uh uh uh uh sal i can't even explain
to you how hard i bomb tonight from metz
owner you're right
no oh my god well maybe you'll get a bit
out of it i can't wait to hear this i'm
so sorry
guys it was insane i'll tell you
tomorrow was wild babe he goes how much
time i said 20 minutes so not terrible
somebody threw camp cake crab cake at me
then you send me
i go somebody threw a camping at me i i
get this voiceover
let me send that right back and then i
go hahaha i go i was at a restaurant in
the city i was getting in but whatever i
said i go
on there we're all eating nobody knew
there was a comedy show going on
it was so crazy tommy motolem all right
carrie's ex-puzzle was there
so i go i love mariah when i was a kid
he yells back i guess you also love [ __ ]
as a kid
place explodes in laughter for the first
time in 20 minutes steve cohen started
yelling at the tv which had the mets
game on calling one of the really
pictures of communists
salah was so nuts from nycc was there
was insane we were dying laughing in the
street
he goes i'm dying i'm dying oh that's me
saying i'm dying right i was just
dying yeah you go i'm dying i'm dying
and then and then and then uh
you go yeah you go i'm dying i'm dying
oh yeah yeah
so so and that was it and then i asked
if you can get me new reebok sneakers
yes
oh by the way those are no problem
they're available
oh really it's not even a hard thing
yeah i can't even get them
they were all sold out on on things
speaking of secrets by the way
somebody made me a pair of sneakers met
sneakers to give like a plug through my
account a plug to give
the meth sneakers to steve cohen i go to
give him the gift he goes i don't want
him you keep them no so i have now the
mess seeks sneakers
i have to make secrets a kid made at
home oh god
we edit that part out i feel like that
kid doesn't know that he genuinely sent
me
he said no you did your part well the
kid sent me a message he was like thank
you so much i can't help defeating it
he was like i can't i can't believe that
the owner of the mets is wearing a pair
of my sneakers i was like yeah he loved
them but he did it
he gave him back you told him that you
he did that what am i going to do tell
him that he
said he said [ __ ] that's not on you tell
him what steve cohen did
let cohen steve cohen deal with it the
fallout from it by the way dave cohen's
been cashing checks for far too long
i want to say steve cohen if you're
listening or if your son's listening i
love you
i that was the f that was honestly you
couldn't have truthfully
you couldn't have been cooler you you
were probably the coolest billionaire
probably the only one i met steve cohen
he was so cool sal
the situation i was in was m it was
impossible i'm i'm talking about empire
impossible
you corrected yourself from the correct
way you said m sorry
impossible that's how you just said
impossible
is it american m impossible
impossible but is it pronounced
impossible is it a mission impossible
impossible in no m like in meaning not
possible
no but it's impossible
yeah hit it again impossible i feel like
it's right on the line of an n and an m
but the the letter that you're staring
at is that's an m yeah
you say impossible you say impossible
is it an imposter an imposter
so there's no all m's babe always has
been always will be
[Laughter]
you know it's not an imposter and it's
not impossible
yeah but you said him and then you went
in impossible
like you were like sorry i almost hit
him but i had it right the first time
yeah so what does that tell you kids
trust your god go
the i i read a study once 90 percent of
the time your first thought is the right
one is that right i should have one made
impossible when i changed the end but
now i'm back to him
um i think i met uh steve cohen i think
i have his business call he was the
nicest guy
yeah he was the nicest guy and listen
maybe this gig is way worse than my hand
and steve or steve's son or anybody if
you're watching don't understand
things that happen in a comedian's mind
in a gig like that maybe i make things
way worse and it wasn't like that and
all these things didn't happen the way
you thought they happened but you got to
understand in my head
and we've all been in this situation it
was i couldn't believe
the gig was so bad the owner of the
restaurant just watched the gig when i
got downstairs he gave me
his business card and told me to call
him because he'd like to buy me a free
dinner for what i just went through
me and my family a free dinner oh my god
yeah no because you know what a good
show is supposed to be like oh you know
what a normal show is
you know what your jokes normally get
yeah they have no basis of comparison
yeah so they might have had fun with you
yeah making fun of you making it knock
it around like
but they don't realize that to you that
was god awful and by the way i do
because the owners of that place are so
nice i do want to shout them out it was
called ostreski's patroon
ostreski's patroon you know you wrote
that to me in a text
yes and i was positive that something
got auto-corrected no it's called a
rescues patron or ostresky's patroon
yeah
what's the patroon i thought you were
trying to say saloon yeah i
cause that's what i said i said did you
guys mean as tresky's
platoon like i think maybe they fought
in like world war ii a patroon
person given land and granted certain
memorial
manor reel manor real privileges under
the former dutch governments of new york
new jersey so it's a dutch
place oh like manor like monorail i
don't know
patroon but what does it have to do with
the russians google is
ostreski's just give it a shot
ostreski's patron
he kind of got very close wow aretsky's
patron aretsky's patroon new york city
midtown east the food there was
fantastic for guys in new york city area
go down to a rescues patroon uh get the
jumbo
uh lump uh crab louie it looks like they
do a good it looks like they're popular
they're well rated but yeah no no no
be honest you know there's so many
restaurants
it's an odd choice you know it's a i
guess you know what
it's a very distinct name but it's not
appetizing or appealing in that way to
me no like oh you want a good great food
you have to go to a retsuki's patron
yeah yeah it's not going to take
a mouthful yeah like that like there
like there's there's a place there was a
place
in in i think long island that i used to
go to after graduate school we would and
the food was great and the drinks were
great but it was called the barefoot
peddler and i was like it's not
appetizing for me to think about bare
feet
enough is enough that's a lot of
syllables i don't like don't have to say
that every time you want to visit
someone
what would it take for you to make to
say i am not going to do
any work anymore at all whatsoever
financially
yeah um like
15 million dollars and then you would
never work again for the rest of your
life no
can't but but but can i like invest that
money and use that money to make money
of course then then 15 million but
that's not a given
i that's uh low to me
in in rel in relation to like i'll never
work again
well what i do what what i think i would
do is i would lose all my interest yeah
i pay the house off something you're
paying the taxes very practical you're
gonna stay in where you are
practically i would you know i'd go i'd
go first class on a trip a year
you know that's very conservative i
thought you were going to say like 100
million
or something like that maybe i should up
it
because we're talking about billionaires
and i was like you know a billion
dollars i couldn't even wrap my head
around spending you know what i mean
maybe i'll say 75 million okay yeah and
then and then you wouldn't even do stand
up you wouldn't do the podcast you
wouldn't do
you'd be like it's perfect retirement
right now
yeah because you you're right if you
gave me i would might spend 15 million
dollars in one year
you you could yeah i mean i i actually
probably would go
absolutely insane right and i would
spend it all on i mean
wild things yeah like by helicopter i
don't even have a license
yeah i don't think you could buy a
helicopter at 15 million you need more
oh you probably could but you'd be going
through that 50 million
pretty fast pretty fast you have to
start doing stand up again i'd say 75.
75 would it be for you 100 number of
billionaires in the world don't look
how many billionaires are there in the
world
this is i mean this is a shot in the
dark billionaires
yeah 3 000 that's absolutely
unbelievable
that's unbelievable what's the answer
cause you almost guessed the population
of
2 750 you are under 250
that's amazing that you guessed 3 000.
because i i figured it's rare because
if there's only 21 million bitcoin ever
going to be made
you know oh is posh is that is that is
is that number inclusive of the
the new wave of crypto millionaires
billionaires
um if there was any let's see what it
was maybe there isn't
that's so many the net worth of the 2750
billionaires is 13 trillion dollars
493 people have been added to the list
as of recent
it is a little crazy oh a trillion is
such a huge number followed by 12 zeros
that is 1 000 times a billion as of
today there are no children oh there are
no trillionaires okay such extreme
wealth we don't see in our lifetime
there probably will be a trillionaire at
some point right
who's yeah it's got i mean it's it's the
way people are becoming billionaires now
uh are by by fake currency
only six trillions trillionaires have
ever lived who's one general
so this just isn't a surviving
trillionaire oh and a hundred trillion
dollars genghis khan's net worth
because of the mongol empire 100 that's
why he was
that's why he was a complete savage at
that point
you gotta there's nothing that could
excite you except maiming and pillaging
jeff bezos would be an absolute
compared to genghis khan he would say
what he is
[ __ ] you're a peasantry what are you
he was like get this filth away from me
yeah to jeff bezos
400 billion dollars a hundred trillion
dollars that means he could put all the
billionaires
money combined he'd still have way more
money ten times more than all the
billions
ten times more than the three thousand
billionaires combined genghis khan
and he slept on a rocks yeah and he
slept on rocks it's a shame
it's a shame he didn't have it's a shame
he didn't have like really like organic
food back then great mattresses
yeah you didn't have any beautiful
leather like a nice leather upper he had
nothing
augustus caesar 4.6 trillion who wait
who's number two
zhao zhao zhu zhao zhu 30 trillion wow
so even the trillionaires if you put all
the trillionaires together genghis khan
has the most money by any person in
history a hundred trillion plus
the i never knew that when i when i
think of genghis khan i don't think
the richest person adjusted for
inflation that ever lived on this planet
and do you want to know what do you want
to know you know what else he killed as
many people as many people because
that's the thing because that's the
thing
did he if the media mean that we as a
society
really wanted to stop the asian hate
you'd bring back genghis khan
nobody's pushing around asians if
genghis is out there on his horse with
his crossbow
that hundred trillion right now though
he would that would go away all his
sponsors would be
pulled pulled he would be cancerous no
i'm saying i'm saying genghis khan
would be counseled he would stop the
asian hate genghis consul
because who because he's asian who's
going to mess with anybody
i know i know what you meant but i know
what you meant yeah well but you know
what or maybe i know this [ __ ]
we got to bring him back let's bring him
back who did he kill everybody though
everybody and they say and they say you
have like if you're alive today you have
like a one percent chance or or
something of being
somehow related to him because he just
pillaged i mean he had sex he had sex
with so many honeys
wow he was like the will chamberlain of
bc
yes yes so we got jacob [ __ ]
jake who's who the [ __ ] is this jacob
flagger
oh for adjusting for translation for
inflation
oh oh so rock jake jacob [ __ ]
is uh adjusted for inflation is more is
richer than
rockefeller how come we've never heard
of jacob [ __ ] rockefeller rockefeller
is that rockefeller is the go-to like
meme like who what am i rockefeller
whose people don't go what am i jacob
[ __ ] of lily
his name was jacob [ __ ] the rich well
i'm i'm gonna be i'm going now with
jacob fagger
yeah i'm gonna be like i'm [ __ ] rich
you just dropped that on someone and
walk away they'll just google and be
like oh yeah
well learned yeah be like yo how much
money is your husband have he got fogger
money
uh a major german merchant mining
entrepreneur and banker he was incentive
of the fugger merchant family located in
the free
imperial city of augsburg where he was
born and later also elevated through
marriage to granberger
of augsburg wow i mean this guy is like
he's uh yeah who's got to be on that
list vanderbilt has to be on that list
now
i thought he was carnegie i always
thought the richest person
in the world ever to exist was
vanderbilt and by the way look at this
elon musk bill gates and jeff bezos the
guys
who are alive right now with the the
richest people in the world are not even
close to a trillion they're 0.04
0.34 and 0.16 respectively i will say
but back then
there was much less current there was
much less
like if you own it it was there were
dynasties back then right so if you
owned everything you owned it
like i think right now there's much more
like in circulation
than there was back then you either were
a complete peasant or you were the
person that ruled
right this kind of thing yeah but
rockefeller richest american ever is
widely considered to be rockefeller
worth about 400 billion
you know so can you look at uh
vanderbilt who i also don't think was
a good guy or apparently he think most
of these people aren't good guys
vanderbilt is buried here on staten
island really yeah the guy
i think why well because staten island
used to be like this is like primo
sound island's coming back it's coming
back baby coming back big time
babe i ripped open a couple of bags of
bare bottom clothing the other day i got
two
i got no less than 30 pieces of bear
shout out to bare bottom clothing they
also wrote me a handwritten note
in there and i really appreciate the
fans of the pod let me tell you
something i got
joggers pants shorts 7-inch
longer ones bathing suits
hoodies yes t-shirts i was thrilled
the pants i'm wearing right now right
bear bottom pants swear to god love them
they sent me a care package too they
sent me a bunch of larges but i'm
actually in exile because i i don't use
my fitness pal anymore and
um my girlfriend's transgender uncle tt
jerry
took some of the larges that i was
supposed to send back and cut them up
and made crop tops and boom boom shorts
with them nothing if he's not creative
but he look he looks good in them he's
gonna post pictures and tag bare bottom
and i want you guys i'm telling you the
clothes is
comfy comfy comfy i love bare bottom if
you're looking for
summer lightweight clothes if you're
looking to like you know go back to
you know go take a dip in the pool um um
the seven inch shorts
because they got five inches which i'm
into seven which i like you guys your
little thigh you show a little knee
little knee i go knee because i have
long testicles so the five inch is a
little lewd
okay seven inch just make it that's nice
that's right what i want you to do is
but you could wear them
you dress them up you dress them down
dress them up down gym and back and
forth and all our listeners can get free
shipping on their first order of these
super comfortable threads at
bearbottomclothing.com with the code hey
babe
just go to barebottomclothing.com that's
bear
like the animal bottomclothing.com
use code hey babe get free shipping on
your first order that's all you got to
do
buy the clothes you need clothes we all
love clothes
bare bottom clothing is uh is uh i want
to bareback you and bare bottom clothing
babe let's talk about babble what you
want to talk about i do
really cool uh language learning app
that i use on my phone on the fly
that they give these 15-minute lessons
that are
not just vocabulary they are more
conversational
they're real world you can apply them in
the real world yes
and i've been brushing up on my espanol
yeah but they have like 14 other
languages
and it it makes it fun and if you're
like me if you have time on a commute
or you go to work every day on a boat a
train or a bus
babel is really cool i think i i
recommend that i want you guys to try it
babel
babel it's it's speech recognition
technology and helps you improve your
pronunciation and accent which is
extremely important
i have been using babel for the past few
months i actually just recently i
haven't told you this and it's big big
news that's coming out actually what's
that
tomorrow it's coming out all over the
news i took a flight
just recently a couple of days ago
that's why i was m.i.a i took a flight
i went to the gaza strip yeah i stood
right in the middle of the
israel-palestine conflicts
uh conflict i spoke to the time i spoke
yeah
i spoke to the left i spoke to the left
in hebrew to the israelites i spoke to
the right and palestinian to the
palestinians i learned both those
languages on babel
the conflict is resolved you'll see that
news tomorrow wow that's something else
well if that is if you want to solve
world conflicts too and religious wars
then you go to right now when you
purchase a three-month babble
subscription you'll get an additional
three months free that's six months
for the price of three go to babel.com
use our promo code hey babe
uh that's b-a-b-b-e-l-dot-com code hey
babe for an
extra three months free shalom allah
america's first great tycoon cornelius
vanderbilt
passed away in 1877 leaving worked a
fortune of 100 million equivalent
to 2.5 billion oh that's nothing i mean
when you think about all this money
that they have like like there was no
reason for stimulus checks
the billion they could have given a
little that's true they could have given
a little bit of coin
right no reason that the government
didn't have this wasn't on the
government granted i get if you had all
that money
you know why would you spend it but also
it's like
you know in a way i know like not
getting deep or anything but in a way
i mean there shouldn't be people that
have half a trillion dollars and also
people that are poor
i mean it's just ridiculous but i don't
know how to fix that i don't know either
but
we're going to figure this we're going
to figure it out on hey babe but by the
end of this by the end of this episode
we'll solve it we'll solve it
world hunger world peace gates is very
altruistic though right he's altruistic
they say he's altruistic did you see by
the way speaking of money ronaldo pushed
away the coca-cola can you see that
thing
no so ronaldo the the soccer player one
of the most famous soccer players in the
world most famous athletes in the world
cristiano ronaldo
hottie with the body from portugal yeah
he he was sitting down
go do about to his press conference he
gets those eyebrows done twice a week
easily there were two bottles of
coca-cola that are sponsors that you
know whatever
and he takes them and puts them out of
the camera frame
and says drink water because he's like i
don't want to promote something that's
unhealthy like that he's not a coca-cola
sponsor but he's like drink agua which
is water in spanish
he says drink i don't know if it's water
in portuguese but it is water in spanish
drink water and he's pushed it away and
coca-cola lost
four billion dollars worth of revenue
the stock went down but it went from
like 260 billion
to 256. crimea river crimea river
crimea syrupy river so it's very
interesting though how because you got
there is
how do they quantify that it was a stock
price that dropped that's what they said
and they're attributing that
solely to him pushing the coca-cola's
out of the way they say that that's the
only thing
that's like musk now uh they're they're
like i think like the the
anonymous people are going after him
because he's toying with the
cryptocurrencies
well that got tricky because then
anonymous made a statement that that
wasn't us
but then how do you verify it's
anonymous yeah
yeah i don't know yes so so yeah but
that's interesting that i don't think
poker ronaldo nothing against coca-cola
and all the fine people and families
that it employs but
it's true we have an epidemic in this
country i kind of i'm a part of it
i kind of same season i i yeah i don't
drink soda but
no but sugar is is is a poison i told
you you got a cold a hotline on
on off of uh for uh your daughter on on
coca-cola coca-cola sugar well she's
well i really do think you know like on
cigarettes
they have like surge in general warning
this will cause cancer they should have
that start putting that on sodas and bad
foods
you because it's like hey hey drink it
go do but you should know that this is
not good
know what you're putting in your body
yeah sugar in moderation is not harmful
however many overdo it
uh americans far too much moderation is
harmful 75
of americans eat excess amounts of sugar
75
i would say i'm i'm i'm strongly in that
75 percent would you say you are
unquestionably i have no doubt about it
i'm in that 75 percent
unquestionably in questionably yes now
is it imbecile or imbecile
m so there's no in no this is in
i think you're also maybe like in in in
in is in is it indigenous or is
it insanity oh it's not imcellent
it's not okay in in okay it is a prefix
that's used
quite often sure i think that you just
indigenous
m also is indiana right right right
wow okay
incomprehensible now see
incomprehensible is it incomprehensible
or m
in in that's where you're getting it
from
no you're okay by the way you were
cyclist i was this whole time i had
rhinoceros whatever
right uh the rhinoceros the whole time
on the show i'm like it's allergies
allergies meanwhile i'm i'm spreading
the rhino
all over all over i had the rhine yeah i
got a covet test and they said
you're negative for covert but what you
are positive for rhinovirus i said i
didn't ask you
to test me for rhinovirus yeah i'll go
to i'll go to my own doctor for the
rhinovirus testing i asked you to test
me for coverage
exactly and you end it there what are
you just going and testing my samples
for the rhinovirus
just sneaking it in yeah i never felt uh
i've never felt like an animal
what is a rhinovirus it's called because
the rhino
this is the rhino plastic rhinoplasty
so this is i think it's it's just a it's
just a a garden variety type virus in
the rhino cavity so they're called the
rhinovirus
so so in in closing i wanted to say
steve cohen i'm not a mess fan of
yankees fan but steve cohen was a very
very great guy
i appreciate um um the generosity he
gave me but that party was tough i
you know it was literally it was rough
it was a rough gig but we've all had
them the life of a stand-up comic at
times isn't glamorous but i will say
i will say i am proud of myself for even
getting through that because i felt like
that took like an experienced comic to
try to even
somehow make something out of that
without a doubt it was 10 guys
i'm not saying i killed i'm not no no
way shape or form but i'm saying you're
bombed
i'm saying i bumped i'm saying exactly
just the opposite i'm saying to
10 guys eating steaks and drinking wines
and having a good time do not
necessarily want to be stopped by a
cordless microphone that isn't on
right to do jokes about whatever
material i'm talking how did steve
cohen's wife like it
no wives were there that's the problem
is we thought
that it was going to be a family party
and it was actually a surprise
10 guys guys night out for steve's
birthday also that's another thing
performing to 10 people is never never
you're never going to get
what you need out of that never it's
like a conversation yeah you had no mic
you were just standing at the top of the
table talking them while they ate steaks
i literally at one point because one guy
was kind of laughing cool i was he was
like you know white guy from
you know i was calling him a human
lacrosse stick and he was liking that
because that's what he looked like
and and i was leaning on his shoulder
like a mic stand
i said can i just use you as the mic
stand he was like absolutely so i was
leaning on his shoulder doing jokes like
like he was like you know like when you
lean on a stool or on a mic stand it was
just that's what i was doing
so he because i literally was imagine
you sitting down with you know at
a table and i just come up after like
when a waiter or waitress is at the
front of the table taking orders that's
what i was doing doing jokes
while they were trying to eat and then
they you know and the one and the guy
closest to me i was above him so he
could he all he could do is listen my
body
was project he couldn't even turn around
and look at me i was over him what's the
least amount of people you ever got on
stage and did a set for
the least amount of people one time i
mean not at a mic when it's just other
comics but like actual
so i had i used to do this place um it's
closed now
i started comedy uh at this place called
the laugh lounge in the lower east side
you ever do the laugh lounge i did not
but okay a bunch of you guys you've
heard of the last launch
so the launch launcher closed it was a
great place now it's a taco place but
the lav lounge 151 essex street i'll
never forget the out just because i was
literally going there yeah you know to
to um
to uh you know perform stand-up and it
was the first club that ever put me in
the room
and they used to quite often because
they weren't ever sure if they were
gonna have a show on monday or tuesday
it depends if like people showed up
so they i was there doing the open mic
at 5 30 and the show was starting at 7
30 and all of a sudden they had people
so she said to me the owner whose name
is was
is delilah like my daughter's name she
said to me she said
hey can you go on stage start the show
the first comic i believe was jonathan
randall
lives a few blocks away i just called
him he's on his way so i said sure
so i go on there's five people all of
them from sweden
there's five people on stage all of them
from sweden
literally i'm on stage for about 10
minutes four of the people
pay the check and leave there's one i
swear to god there's one person you're
already in the set
i'm already in the set i have no i they
left because they were just like it's
not for us
yeah i've performed for this guy this
one guy from sweden for probably about
another 20 to 30 minutes before jonathan
rambo got there obviously not laughing
he's politely laughing whatever
and i don't even think to ask this
jonathan randall gets on stage take some
mic goes give it up for chris the one
guy claps
john the first question he goes do you
speak english and the guy goes
no yeah he goes english amazing and he
goes no i didn't even think to ask that
i was doing jokes i mean high brow jokes
about specifically the g-train
in manhattan on the subway system i mean
this guy knows the lick of english
but then as when randall got on a family
came down like or uh you know group of
people came down who did speak english
from america
and sent to the show but that was that
was the longest person
one person for about four people
initially starting with five went down
to one
that would say the time i was in florida
with the guys you're playing the hard
rock in like uh
whatever fort lauderdale whatever
florida wherever that is and uh
during the show in the back of the room
the cops come come in and arrest someone
during the show
wow it was way in the back but we heard
a commotion right i figured there was a
fight
figure there was a fight no people were
[ __ ]
the show during the show in their seats
having in the hard rock theater
venue came in arrested and walked them
out after the show we go back we go what
happened back there fight or whatever
you're not gonna believe it you're not
going to believe it two people were
having sex in their seat someone called
the cops on
wow yeah wow i believe that florida
florida that's what happens
um speaking of having sex in the back of
the hard rock cafe in florida
steven seagal yes has defected from the
united states
given up citizenship and now is a member
of the pro-kremlin
russian party and has fully denounced
u.s citizenship and now fully lives
as a russian citizen that can't be true
look at it hollywood actor steven seagal
long time admirer russian president
vladimir putin has joined a pro club
kremlin party
i thought he was like a no dude he was
in politics wasn't the exact
opposite of that wasn't he like a
sheriff down south yeah well we thought
he was
he's a russian citizen since 2007.
actually he's been working for the
russian government as a spy this
entire time the whole plan was to make
him a superstar movie star wow
because everyone has always said like
his movies aren't you know i mean his
movies are fun to watch but you know no
one is like always the greatest actor of
all time well he had a little
like a three or four movie run that was
like popular but then the rest were all
like
he kept doing them but i don't i don't
think they they fell out of the table
but was it doesn't he isn't he known and
i guess i'm never gonna cross his path
right because he's a russian citizen now
he's a russian citizen lives over there
so maybe i won't get cigaled because
i will tell you this as old he's a he's
a he's a unique looking fellow
very unique odd looking duck no odd
looking he's got that like widow's peak
yeah he's only 69 i thought he was older
you know here's the thing
as he gets older he doesn't get less
scary he's like tyson in that way
right i always fear seagal but i'm
wondering at
69 if seagal squared up again not that i
i can't fight and i'm not a tough person
but
there's got to be there's got to be a
tipping point it's true
it's true there's got to be a tipping
point though you do get mad though i've
seen you get mad
have you well not mad but you told me a
story once about how you got
we've all woken up a little bit of hair
on our pillow all of us have woken up
with a little bit of hair on our pillow
and said oh my god
pump the brakes what's going on how do i
keep what i have
hot do you pump for hair loss say again
remember the bumper sticker thing you
were saying do you pump her oh break
do you break for hair loss sorry yeah
but break for hair loss means you like
hair loss we don't
you want to get keeps yeah keep here's
some stats that are sobering two out of
three men will experience
a form of hair loss before 35. wow 50
million men in the u.s suffer from male
pattern boldness
and there are only two fda approved
medications that can prevent it keeps
offers both
keeps it's a simple stress-free way to
keep your hair it's low cost
listen to this treatments are only 10
bucks a month and it keeps offers
generic
and uh treatments are only ten dollars a
month and they offer you all the generic
versions they have more five star
reviews than any of their competitors
any single one of their competitors
prevention is key
treatments can take four to six months
to see results
so act fast you balding pieces of [ __ ]
that's right if you're ready to take
action now
your son's a [ __ ] to prevent hair loss
go to k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash hey babe don't be a piece
of [ __ ] you'll receive your first month
treatment for free
that's k-e-p-s dot com slash hey babe
this is in your wheelhouse because it's
an online graphic
design tool is that what it is yeah i
use this all the time you pretty much
pay them
their fee and you get access to stock
photos and templates for your business
card or your flyer
or even stock video you can use in an
edit like i have for hey babe
oh wow okay so canva pro is used on the
show oh yeah
absolutely okay yeah it's everything you
need in one place including collection
over 75 million
premium photos videos orders and
graphics that's cool because when you're
whenever you're looking for anything
images b-roll this that the other you're
always like are these royalty-free are
they not do i have the right hand
that's cool well i gotta tell you i mean
i can't tell you how many messages i get
i'm sure you get
um the same cell about how much they
love the edits and the graphics on hey
babe and that's all pimp using canva pro
that's all we get that all the time and
people love the editing and love what
pimp does
we've seen a lot of people they want to
do that now so they have a deal for us
do they have a deal can't canva pro for
our listeners but it's also it's
actually i'll point out because i'm
reading it here and i'd love to try it
too
because it's not just for people at
pimp's level it's no matter what level
you're at it says
right so anybody who wants it it's kind
of easy to use
uh i like that i like that a lot okay so
you don't have to have autism to know
how to do this
you don't have to okay no you'll be all
right it's just
it just takes the one subscription
designed like a pro camera pro right now
you get a free 45-day extended trial
when you use our promo code just go to
canva that's c-a-n-v-a
dot me slash hey babe canva dot me
hey babe to get a free 45-day extended
trial c-a-n-v-a
dot m-e slash hey babe can without
me slash a [ __ ] canva don't mean a babe
canva dot me slash hey babe
canva.
[Laughter]
what i'm saying is push comes to shove
you'll you'll you'll fight you will
fight
push comes to shove you're a very nice
pleasant guy but you're not a [ __ ] is
what i'll say
sure i'll try to protect myself if worse
comes to yourself
um yeah i think you were talking about
that time that someone like accosted me
and i got mad is that what it was on the
street told me about it yeah
yeah but i'm not but i think there's got
to be a tipping point even with sergal
where like i could take them like you
ever think about this sometimes i think
about
if i go back in time like there's a time
where i was better at basketball than
lebron james
it's a fact there has to be until he
until he came into his own at like
eight i could exploded lebron because
you're a couple years older
lebron james is born what like 83.
lebron james
very different 1989 i would lebron james
up in the game of one-on-one or vice
versa or anything like that and i'm not
even i'm not even that great
at basketball i'm not even good at it
sorry sorry no problem james madden
calling me oh i thought it was uh
no birth control no but let's say birth
control
but you know what i'm saying i could
just i could just tee off on lebron
and vice versa now right there's going
to be a point where i could really take
seagal out if i need to
yes and it's probably it's not yet but
when he's in his mid 80s but he's still
scary though still scary and his face
got
very big his face it covers a lot of
surface
area yeah uh you know what else you know
what gets me it's
every movie he had that maneuver where
he just would break the arm the other
way
or break the knee the reverse way it
looks painful he does it with gusto and
he does it swiftly and effectively
and i know that's a movie but i feel
like he's got that in him
no matter what so even if i throw
something at him he might be able to
just snap my own no no no no no listen
the actors a mark wahlberg ryan reynolds
the action stars who do all those
sequences yes there are times where
stunt doubles come in and do it but they
have learned how to fight from being in
the movies like
yes there's a showmanship of being in
movies but they know how to fight now
ryan reynolds would
beat the [ __ ] out of you just from the
yeah
he would beat the [ __ ] i mean without
deadpool but when they go through this
training then it's for sure but a lot of
them are small
like tom hardy's a small guy i i heard
that get you on the floor you're done
he's a small guy now listen but he's got
to train for all his boxers i'm saying
bane and the boxing moves i mean
but i'm just saying like they're they're
small guy like like you know like al
pacino
yeah he's a small guy he's a small guy
he's small tom cruise i heard too
small very small meaning probably my
height i'm 5 10. i'm not like
steven seagal broke sean connery's wrist
while filming never say never again
broke his heart
wow first question what does never say
never again i would say 95 percent of
steven seagal movies
most people have never seen yeah
that's a famous bond movie though so was
seagal in this before he was seagal
was he like this was 1983 was seagal
famous in 1983
hell no no when did segal get famous
like late 80s right
i don't know above the law i think it
was
above the law so above the law was
seagal's first so that means steven
segov he's 69 years old now
he only got famous in his late 30s how
is he cranking out two movies a year now
from russia
and it's done same movie over and over
and over yeah
not 25 uh above the law
1988 was his number one that was the
first movie
alpha justice see yeah that he put it
together a real string where he was like
the go-to action guy right
right right 88 so segal was about 30 he
was my age cigar
so if i'm going to make it in the movies
that stephen cigar i need to start right
now
you need to find the next stephen cigar
i need to start immediately because i'm
going to be 37 in two months
he has a movie out last year though at
68 he's still doing 69 he's still doing
now he sings songs he collaborated with
stevie wonder for his debut album no he
did not that's
[ __ ] it starts is stevie wonder
if stevie wonder collaborated with
steven seagal i would be
shocked that can't be true it can't be
true
it's it's him playing right on cv-1 the
first day of you album
come on i want to hear the song
stephen's also have a house on staten
island he did yeah
crazy is he still married to kelly
lebrock let's see stephen kelly the
brock was a
siren siren my release this is
steven seagal and stevie wonder yeah
put it forward a little bit i want to
hear your stevie what would you
categorize this music as
adult contemporary elevator elevator
elevator
no disrespect to stevie who is this for
our moms the confluence of seagulls fans
and stevie wonders fans that's some
crowd
that's a crowd
i almost want to make it a point to see
it live yeah
would you go to moscow i would book
passage tonight have you been in russia
no i mean we got to go to antarctica
i would go you've been australia yes
great
i was there for like a month am i
supposed to go back and film again
you were there in australia for a month
yes doing uh jokers
no we were supposed to go there and film
i went on vacation you want a vacation
to australia
never i would never i thought i would
never see it right because i won't take
that flight and i said if i ever go
and i take that flight it was three
weeks i was like i'm gonna go
substantially
and see a lot of parts of it because i
may never go back right and so i i
when we were off we were hiatus i
cleared it and i went you went
you went all around the whole country i
went for two or three three full weeks
yeah wow it was
i loved it unbelievable yeah you went
from melbourne to sydney and all around
i didn't know new zealand you hit new
zealand i didn't but i will next time
right
i will if i go back even maybe tasmania
nice
tanzania how many years ago did you hit
australia uh
was like two three years ago so three
years ago okay yeah it was actually i
was actually it was made two years ago i
was doing the fires which was
i did not encounter them uh save for
when i went to sydney we were getting
the winds
and in sydney there was literally you
could smell the wildfire throughout the
city they were giving masks out
at the hotel so you you got me to the
mass way before the pandemic yeah yeah
exactly right yeah who would have known
foreshadowing foreshadowing
amazing okay oh we got to get to
australia um steven seagal got sued for
driving a tank and killing a dog
yeah wow well what can you do teamed up
with the sheriff
i mean broke sean connery's wrist he's
killing dogs with a tank is steven
seagal a good guy
email hey bay podcaster gmail is is hey
bay podcast is that what it is
hey bay park drove pilot gmail.com drove
a tank into a house belonging to a man
suspected of being part of a [ __ ]
fighting ring
he's eating so you know what he actually
want a sentence
okay so actually i take that back good
guy he's trying to break up the
cockfight ring and unfortunately
the spoils of war sometimes what happens
is you kill him a dog he's
he's live he's lived a fruitful life
yeah can you tell me if he's still
married to kelly lebrock yeah all of
this from a home on staten island
you you you you've seen you know kelly
the brock you've seen weird science
you know she was like the loreal she was
a supermodel back in the i guess 80s 90s
they divorced in 96. oh it's been a
while so he's married
he's currently he's got four wives she
had adrian larussa from 1984 to 1984 so
that was a quickie
miyako fujitani 1974 to 87
then in 87 to 96 kelly lebrock and then
most recently
aaron dentuya seagal who was still
married to in 2009.
let me tell you something i never really
get those marriages like 1984 to 1984.
it was a quickie
i know like that's really bad judgment
right because
i mean you can't make it work longer
than you're committing
you're saying till death do you part and
then piecing out and under 12 needless
i'm one of one of my friends i went to a
friend's wedding
at the wedding at the wedding we were
all saying this there is no
chance they're gonna last sal i [ __ ] you
not
they went on their honeymoon for
whatever two weeks
when they when you know whatever you
know you go to the wedding the wedding
was in mexico
honeymoon two weeks get a group text
from the guy hey guys we decided to call
it off in the honeymoon so we're gonna
get a divorce but i appreciate you being
there i know it was short
it was a mistake so they literally i
know i know a couple that were married
for
two weeks called it off did you no
cheating no nothing just realized that
the honeymoon it wasn't right they were
dating for six seven years
are you kidding me honeymoon done now
they're fully divorced
do you think they knew beforehand that
they were on the outs and they had the
wedding just for the
just for the gifts for the party i think
so do you think so
you had another wedding that you went to
where the
didn't the the the you told me this on
maybe on this podcast
the bride didn't show well that was the
yeah when i was working but that wasn't
a friend of mine i was working i was a
bartender on a cruise
okay yes yes yes yeah and the bartender
yeah the guy the guy they didn't show up
that's wild while there are countless
divorce studies with conflict
conflicting statistics the data points
to two periods
during a marriage when divorce are most
common years one to two and
five to eight interesting three and four
you're relatively safe
of those two high-risk periods there are
two years in particular that stand out
as the most common years in divorce
you're seven and eight
wow you're seven and eight is when the
most most
marriages fail what do you think happens
in that stride of seven eight i think
seven and eight you're probably like
really settling into the person it
really starts to dawn on you
like wow this is gonna be my whole life
and you start to maybe nitpick at things
you like
that you don't like about them around
year seven or eight substantial enough
to have a body of a relationship behind
you
and saying hey we've tried this for a
while better
right right getting better with you babe
and then you go and then
and also maybe at year seven eight maybe
the kids that you've had are a little
bit more grown
and then you're like we wanted to get
out of this earlier but not with you but
you can't leave you can't leave a
newborn you know what i mean
hit it nearly 80 of divorced people get
remarried
six percent of people even remarry the
same spouse as you age
prospects of remarrying do not decrease
in fact the remarriage rate for those
over 55 has increased in recent years
wow
increased damn i'm not i i've never been
married
um but you know i don't know
i'm not against it i'm not against it
but
because like i had
my daughter first without marrying her
and you know
i kind of feel like you know
we're connected so why do i why do we
got to go put it on paper
you know what i'm trying to say yeah if
we didn't have the kid first
i'd say we're connected now because the
ring and then we got the kid and
nothing bonds you more than a shared
child so it almost seems like that was
the
ultimate and this is the penultimate
yeah so and obviously you know
my girlfriend gets pissed you know but
it's just like hey like that's just what
that's how i'm like i just that's the
way i think about it
but i'm not saying never i'm not saying
never with a marriage
i'm just saying right now well now
you're gonna share two two children
yeah you're in each other's lives what
you live together we gotta i mean
what is that called when you uh common
law like what is it which doesn't exist
in new york
common law they got rid of it when who
kamala is out who did that google common
law in new york done out
who knows commonly i mean you lived
together long enough where
they're just like yeah you're married
you're married yeah common law
common law america does not allow common
law marriages regardless of how couples
been living together
however in states that permit common law
marriage if the marriage is recognized
as a valid common law marriage in that
state
then new york state will honor that
marriage in new york so does that mean
you have all the uh fixings and
trimmings and accoutrements of a regular
marriage
but without any of the hassle stress
paperwork or party
yes so how long is that i would strive
for that
because then you're achieving the same
result but you're not spending all this
money
making people take off from work come to
your wedding you're not signing all the
paperwork the gov's not get or the
government is automatically involved
well can you renounce common law is
common law just assumed or is it like
if you say you are you are but what have
you me me and my spouse live together
for 20 years
in a common law state and they say
you're common law no we ain't like no
you're common law no no you're not
no you're not so you have to you have to
opt in around yeah because because you
have to go to court to file a domestic
partnership
oh so you still have to do paperwork to
take advantage of the common law
management i would imagine
uh so you just don't have to well how's
that any different than going and just
starting the paperwork to be married
that's what i'm saying i don't
understand it i haven't understood it
if i wanna if i wanna marry someone
we go down we get a marriage license a
witness comes
city hall they stamp it you're married
you're married so
if it's the way it's just for you that
doesn't mean anything in the eyes of the
lord
you got you got the marriage certificate
happens nobody's that the marriage no
good place
so if you have to do all that to get
regular married but then common law
marriage you go down and sign paperwork
too what's the difference
there is no difference please someone
marriage is a legal union between two
people that requires a license and a
ceremony in most states
the ceremony though is bs it happens at
a city hall if you
just it doesn't you don't need a
reception but in a handful of states you
and your partner have been living
together and
behaving as if you were married so much
just like fighting every day
yeah you may have what's known as a
common law marriage it's not automatic
there are rules you must follow but my
question to you is is okay
so yeah so where to get so
let's say i'm with a woman 20 years not
in the state of new york
so we're we're where common law marriage
doesn't exist but technically we're like
kind of common law
if i you know and the kids are older so
no more childs obviously always pay for
the kids i don't have to give alimony
and she doesn't have to give me alimony
if she makes more money because we're
common-law married
it's common telling me that or is that
we're supposed to be asking you i don't
understand it
i mean i do always let me ask you a
question if you get common-law married
right
and then people go is this your wife do
you always do you give the caveat every
time
it's coming long yeah i would say i
would one i would say i was
thrilled with each other i would say hey
i would say hey you know nice to meet
you guys this is jasmine my common wife
what is common law marriage uh a concept
that has been around since the 1800s wow
so that's relevant the idea allows
couples to be legally married without
the formality of a ceremony
witness and marriage license so so i
don't literally
stand so i could go to i could i could
say i'm common law married to anybody
yeah there's no rules i'm like i'm
common law marriage you say no you know
i'm like well i am
so if we were roommates because now uh
uh gay marriage is legal
so if we were roommates in a common law
state for like 10 years
we could just be like common law has
common law has
that's it i could do it yeah what is
that tax implication what about common
law marriage can i get your insurance
benefits if i don't have insurance
this is all someone oh if you're a
listener
that is common law married please please
tell us all the rules in the in the
comments
gmail.com for your common law questions
and answers
gmail.com common law married because
here's what i'll say
about marriage is i think in a way now
because i get getting married you know
years ago
you didn't meet anybody outside your
village it was good for legal reasons
and tax reasons but now
you know now you get married it's like
all right you know you really love the
person great
tax purposes tax purposes genius
i'll get i'm gonna get married you're
gonna do it yeah to my my girlfriend now
we're definitely getting married do it
yeah we are 100 yeah i would do it i
think you two should get married at a
live show
we could on the patreon why not
we we could i almost i almost married uh
louis gomez and dave smith one time but
dave wouldn't agree to it
why wouldn't he agree to it uh he just
thought it was to be hassle
but but lewis had such a funny he's like
anywhere we go he goes we'll annul it
immediately
but then for life anywhere we go we
could be like ah my ex-husband just got
here
it it was really funny right yeah um um
so yeah i i the thing is with marriage i
know
i don't know i don't know now you know
she's gonna hear this and i'm
what's one more fight
you're really acting like common law
married people that's what it is what's
the difference
at this point you know we've been common
lords for so long we've been coming
america for so long it's whatever
yeah the old bag i want to uh
people say that about their wife i think
they say my old lady old lady
ball and change the old boy i guess is
not to i mean that's not too great
ball and chain no old lady i i thought
it was like an endearing thing
my old lady maybe you've been with her a
long time right my old fellow my old
lady
but uh my old bag you call that i guess
so i don't know
that that seems pejorative yeah i didn't
mean to say it
my old lady i think my old lady
originated from scottish as in me old
lady which was a way of saying my love
to the special lady of your life
or a way of showing acknowledgement and
respect to an older lady in your life
but i mean still
calling even in scottish times calling
your wife or girlfriend he's very young
and beautiful my old ladies can't feel
great
yeah i don't think women like to be
called hey this is my old lady
right i mean i wouldn't like that yeah i
never really take that one as an insult
though i always take it as like
a cutesy thing old bag that one i gotta
get rid of
all bags you gotta stop referring to it
as my old bed maybe that's why we
sound like a nut sack yeah my old bag
okay blood yeah broad broad is not broad
is uh
is not good not good derivatives i mean
i don't think people know when they say
it but i think broad is definitely
derogatory so it's a well it signifies a
female provider for a pimp
oh really i thought it was something
else a female companion of woman of
loose
morals got it broad is derived from the
far-fetched metaphor of a meal ticket
okay signifying a female provider for a
pimp
from the fanciful correspondence of a
meal ticket
to a railroad or other ticket but still
where does the word broad come from
that's all it's not as bad as i thought
then
well it's terrible for a you know pimp
it's hard out here for a pm yeah
i don't know what you heard about pimp
if you if we ever do a live show you got
to come out to that that
speaking of bro you know he's very
broadly known who tom brady
tom brady very broadly known and you
know what just happened to him he won
the super bowl
god bless that man 43 years of age
oldest person in the nfl
tampa bay buccaneers in his home stadium
in tampa never been done before and
won't probably ever be done again
beat kansas city chiefs patrick holmes
shout out good uh great game kid
mahomes has a big big career ahead of
him he really does have a big big
shout out to the chiefs yeah good
organization dude patrick mahomes
unbelievable guy um oh my god dude and
you know what
actually is um andrew santino
you know a friend of the show doesn't he
know mahomes he knows mahomes he knows
pastoral homes patrick williams
came to his comedy show uh i believe in
dallas came to this comedy show santino
told me dude the stuff about mahomes
this has been a baby
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away
from your feelings bae don't be afraid
don't be ashamed don't hesitate to say
hey
babe hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey